[Music]
along with the latest DC hero to get his
own movie we're bringing you an rt25 fan
favorite about a different DC character
think bats instead of beetles plus a
Full Slate of animated options that
includes a movie based on a 16th century
novel an R-rated comedy with a doggone
good cast and the return of a popular
Hulu show this is what to watch
acquired who said that systems
Landing in theaters is the DC Superhero
film Blue Beetle this character dates
back to comic book pages from 1939 and
derives his powers from a Scarab that
gives him the ability to produce a super
strong exoskeleton around his form and
create various tools and weapons based
on whatever he can imagine that classic
coolness is reason number one to give
this a try another big reason is set a
viewing trap for this beetle is that it
marks the first solo live action film
for a Latino superhero on top of that
director Angel Manuel Soto said that
building an authentic Mexican-American
family around the main star with a
variety of accents and experiences
similar to the comics was a big part of
making this film as for a third reason
to check this one out take your pick how
about the fact that Susan Sarandon is
playing a villain or that Blue Beetle
AKA Jaime Reyes is played by sholomere
duena of Cobra Kai Fame in his first
lead film role get it cholo we're
tonight's entertainment
well hello beautiful
another great option for this week is a
brand new flick called The Dark Knight
no wait it's actually one of the best
movies of the past quarter century and
is the winner of the rt25 fan vote pick
we asked fans to vote for their favorite
movies from the last 25 years and to no
one's surprise really The Dark Knight
came out on top maintaining a 94
audience score with over 500 000
audience ratings since it was released
in 2008 and if you know anything about
people and movie fans especially that's
an impressive feat no offense to
everybody watching on top of that fan
love the critics have been feeling this
one for quite a while too in fact we
surveyed a bunch of individually
approved Tomato Meter critics about
their favorite movies from the past 25
years and this was number four after we
tallied everything up another great
reason to re-watch it also The Dark
Knight garnered some serious accolades
in part because of the magnetic
performance of the late Heath Ledger he
posthumously won a best supporting actor
Oscar as part of two wins in a total of
eight nominations to go along with over
a billion dollars earned at the box
office just that you know
sort of
Monkey King
hitting Netflix this week is the
computer animated flick The Monkey King
this fantasy comedy was inspired by the
Epic Ming Dynasty novel Journey to the
West which was published in the 16th
century and is one of the most popular
literary Works in East Asia so yeah it's
the first reason to give this one a try
plus the title character is voiced by
Jimmy o Yang who you no doubt loved in
Silicon Valley and he takes on the
Dragon King Voice by Bowen Yang who you
loved on SNL that's reason number two
and 2.1 to enjoy The Monkey King the
final reason is that director Anthony
Stacy has a pretty impressive background
he was a long time effects animator at
industrial Light and Magic worked on
films like Back to the Future 2 and 3
hook The Rocketeer and James and the
Giant Peach but really I had to add Back
to the Future too didn't I yeah
even under these strange circumstances
wandering into theaters is another
animal offering Strays this R-rated
comedy comes with a super impressive
first reason to check it out and that's
its voice cast it includes Will Ferrell
Jamie Foxx Will Forte Isla Fisher
Randall Park and Sophia Vergara I could
name even more like Rob Riggle but they
told me to move on Josh cat the film
follows an abandoned dog who ends up
joining with other Strays as they help
him get revenge on his former owner
which sounds like a great reason to bark
up this tree unless of course you've
been a bad dog owner shame on you and
Strays was produced by Phil Lord and
Christopher Miller whose names might
sound familiar as the writers and
directors of Cloudy With a Chance of
Meatballs and The Lego Movie not to
mention the live-action 22 and 21 Jump
Streets
a big part of the mission is US fitting
in on Earth everyone looked like a
perfect non-wear family why do you have
to be like this and flying in from out
of this world on Hulu for a fourth
season solar opposite look no further
than the Tomato Meter for the first
reason to tune into this series where
the previous three seasons are all fresh
including two of them at 100 and the
Tomato Meter doesn't go above that
believe me we've tried the critics have
called it Charming hilarious and
surprisingly sincere another reason to
check it out is that both creators have
worked on other great projects
previously like Rick and Morty and Mike
McMahon on Star Trek below decks both
great shows and lastly don't forget
about the wonderful voice cast who are
returning for season four which includes
Thomas middleditch Christina Hendricks
Alfred Molina Sterling K Brown and
Kieran Culkin we would name more but
we're getting the wrap it up signal so
let's do that
well there it is five picks that will
certainly brighten up your Dark Knight
be sure to let us and your fellow
viewers know in the comments what you
did check out weather was on this list
or not remember to check out
rottentomatoes.com for the latest
updates on scores and reviews for
everything mentioned as well as the
movie and TV World At Large that's all
for today fresh family until next week
stay fresh